[Musique]
bonsoir à tous au sommaire de ça vous
regarde ce soir la fronde des petits
commerçants contraints de baisser le
rideau le gouvernement est il allé trop
loin
est ce que le seuil d'acceptabilité
n'est pas dépassée et l'opposition de
son côté est ce qu'elle ne joue pas un
peu avec le feu à soutenir cette fronde
en pleine crise sanitaire
la crise sanitaire justement on va en
parler puisque la deuxième vague
pourrait bien n'être plus forte que la
première
les hôpitaux vont ils pouvoir y faire
face et ce que l'on va vers un prix des
patients à l'entrée des services de
réanimation est ce que l'on a par
confiner un peu trop tard toutes ces
questions nous les poserons à nos
invités enfin notre face à face sera
consacré un documentaire à voir demain
soir sur lcp prof en territoires perdus
de la république
il a été tourné en 2015 mais il est plus
que jamais d'actualité aujourd'hui
après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit voilà
pour le sommaire on compte sur vous pour
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
mot clé c'est v r
[Musique]
et un mot d'abord pour vous expliquer
pourquoi nous avons décidé de porter le
masque en plateau désormais c'est une
décision un choix des cp qui se veut
évidemment exemplaire dans cette période
où on demande des efforts à chacun pour
limiter les risques de contamination et
puis c'est aussi une décision qui a été
prise en accord avec l'assemblée et son
protocole sanitaire puisque nos studios
sont situés dans les locaux de
l'assemblée
j'accueille donc avec plaisir nos
invités masques et julien aubert bonsoir
qu'on me reconnaît bonsoir oui on vous
reconnaît je replace le masque qui
descend donc vous êtes député les
républicains du vaucluse vous êtes
membre de la commission d' enquête aussi
sur la gestion de la crise du
coronavirus nous sommes aussi en liaison
à distance avec lionel saugues bonsoir
vous êtes vice président de la
confédération des commerçants de france
et puis dans quelques instants nous
rejoindre julien bobroff zik qui est
député la république en marche de la
loire le département le plus touché
actuellement par la seconde vague et qui
est aussi président de la commission d'
enquête sur la gestion de la crise du
coronavirus il est en train de quitter
l'hémicycle pour nous rejoindre c'est
donc une colère qui monte et qui en dit
long sur la difficulté à faire accepter
ce nouveau confinement la colère des
petits commerçants obligé de baisser le
rideau à quelques semaines des fêtes de
fin d'année poussan donc des millions de
français à faire leurs courses de noël
sur amazon qui peut rester ouvert qui
doit fermer et pourquoi
quels produits les supermarchés
doivent-ils retirer oui aux déodorants
non aux parfums et les livres pourquoi
est ce qu'ils ne sont pas jugées
indispensables au bien-être des français
c'est le thème de la chronique de
stéphane blakowski
[Musique]
alors si j'ai bien compris stéphane ben
si j'ai bien compris comment on commence
à sentir la colère qui monte dans le
pays a oui c'était un petit peu bizarre
jusque là parce que quand même la france
les pays d gilet jaune des gaulois
réfractaires le pays de la révolution
et pourtant on avait l'impression au
début de ce nouveau confinement que
c'était à peu près accepté par tout le
monde en tout cas c'est ce que disaient
les sondages 1 ce week-end à peut-être
jeter un oeil sur la une du parisien
voilà 71% des français répondait au quai
au sondeur qu'ils étaient prêts pour un
noël confiné alors à noël confiné pour
les français oui mais pas pour tout le
monde ya une colère qui monte on l'a dit
la colère des petits commerçants
exactement la colère des petits
commerçants pourtant les petits
commerçants ils vont quand même pas la
réputation d'être des des
révolutionnaires un sauf qu'aujourd'hui
le confinement ils risquent de ruiner
leur vie donc il pourrait vite les
petits commerçants passé du côté des
mécontents ceux qui n'ont rien à perdre
et qui n'ont que la colère pour exprimer
leurs revendications pour se rendre
compte de leur état d'esprit on écoute
françoise klein qui est le patron des
petits patrons
tout d'abord une pensée très profond de
très intime à tous ceux qui sont
victimes d'une fermeture administrative
le sol se dérobe sous leurs pieds ce
sont pour l'essentiel des travailleurs
non salariés
pas de chiffre d'affaires le commerce
est fermé l'activité s'arrête pas de
revenus pas de salaire des dettes
voilà ce qu'ils ont comme perspective
c'est catastrophique alors cette
inquiétude
évidemment on est obligé de la
comprendre mais ce qui pourrait se
passer que c'est que c'est un set un
quitus qu'il se transforme-t-elle
voulait dit en colère et ça il ya un
facteur qui serait essentiel pour ça
c'est le sentiment d'injustice parce que
la justice y'a rien de tel pour attiser
la colère voyez les titres dans la
presse régionale aujourd'hui je vous ai
pris un exemple dans le courrier
cauchois donc c'est la ville de fécamp
où les commerçants cris justement
analystes à l'injustice mais c'est
pareil dans toute la presse régionale
alors le résultat c'est que
bruno le maire a passé un mot à mot le
week-end il s'était un peu inquiété en
fait on a vu dans le parisien ce matin
que sa grande inquiétude c'est que la
colère des petits commerçants les pousse
finalement à faire des blocus autour des
supermarchés en empêchant les
consommateurs d'y accéder un peu à la
manière des agriculteurs quand ils
veulent exprimer leur mécontentement
et donc c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement a décidé de pénaliser les
grandes surfaces du exactement bah oui
on est en france en france on a la
passion de l'égalité alors puisque
certains petits commerces sont pénalisés
par le confinement dans un souci
d'équité évidemment le gouvernement a
décidé de pénaliser aussi les grandes
surfaces en leur interdisant de vendée
fameux produits non essentiels le
résultat c'est quoi bas c'est qu'on va
réduire de 15 à 20 % le chiffre
d'affaires des grandes surfaces dans
l'espoir d'apaiser la colère des petits
commerçants qui sont au bord du dépôt de
bilan alors une sorte de logique de
perdant-perdant on se dit que si tout le
monde est perdant
eh ben ça fera peut-être moins de jaloux
mais y aura quand même un gagnant dans
tout ça a priori ça risque d'être amazon
ben forcément ce qu'on a plus droit
d'acheter dans les petits commerces ni
dans les grandes surfaces restent
disponibles dans les commerces en ligne
il y en a un qui se frotte les mains
c'est jeff bezos le patron d'amazon
enfin ce qu'a dit bruno le maire était à
l'assemblée cet aprem pour répondre au
député et il tenait à relativiser un
petit peu le poids d'amazon à l'ecoute
on avait tous que amazon à la bouche et
je vous remercie de faire dans cet
hémicycle la publicité d'amazon
j'aurais simplement dire qu'il ne
représente que 20% du commerce en ligne
et qui devraient s' 80% du commerce en
ligne
je veux bien que vous taxi et le
commerce en ligne
mais dans ce cas là c'est le commerce
français que vous allez taxer demain le
rêve du gouvernement ça serait que tous
les petits commerçants se se
convertissent au commerce en ligne le
fameux click and collect un clic et et
puis ont emporté il ya quand même un
problème c'est que à l'heure actuelle
les deux tiers des petits commerces
n'ont même pas de site internet donc
autant dire que c'est pas gagné donc moi
c'est inquiétudes des commerçants mais
évidemment je suis comme tout le monde
je la comprends d'abord je voudrais
rappeler comme que
à l'issue du premier confinement il ya
un million de français qui ont basculé
dans la pauvreté
est ce que à chaque confinement il ya un
million de français de plus qui vont
basculer dans la pauvreté
je trouve pas au moins aussi inquiétant
de la situation sanitaire
ben oui il me semble que le gouvernement
si le besco une question aujourd'hui
c'est est ce qu'il serait pas temps
avant que tout le pays soit en colère
daté de mai un petit peu l'effet du
confinement peut-être notamment pour les
petits commerçants
c'est une question qu'on va poser à nos
invités évidemment merci stéphane je me
tourne vers vous julien gourraud musique
merci de nous avoir rejoints avant de
parler du sort des petits commerçants un
mot tabou tout d'abord de cette gestion
de la crise on a l'impression un peu
d'une gestion au fil de l'eau un peu
comme ça à vue de nez en temps réel et
du coup il ya il ya des couacs il ya
parfois des contradictions aussi dans
l'est dans les prises de position du
gouvernement
oui là vous allez me reparler de
l'épisode d'aujourd'hui on en parlera
plus tard sur le couvre-feu éventuelle à
paris mais d'abord sur ce qui a pu être
dit et fait sur les petits commerces non
essentiels bah écoutez il ya eu une mise
en place du confinement comme il avait
été fait lors de la du premier
confinement s'agissant des petits
commerces
il y avait une volonté ça va ça vient de
l'être dit mais de manière différente
mais de réduire les problèmes d'équité
mais je crois que en dessous de tout ça
n'oublions pas parce que j'aimerais
quand même qu'on le rappelle est
peut-être ma monde ma fibre médical mais
il y à une crise sanitaire majeure
il faut pas l'oublier et on aura
l'occasion d'en rediscuter en parler
dans la deuxième partie de l'émission et
vous resterez avec vous est d'ailleurs
d'en débattre parce que j'entends moi
aussi les commerçants tous autant qu'ils
sont parce que n'imaginais pas qu'on se
lève le matin en disant tiens qui sait
qu'on pourrait embêter ce matin où
aujourd'hui mais on écoute aussi les
personnes qui travaillent dans les
hôpitaux et j'étais encore au téléphone
avec les anesthésistes et urgentistes de
du chu de saint-etienne tout à l'heure
au téléphone surtout inquiets de la
crise actuelle et de la tv département
c'est le départements les plus touchés
aujourd'hui il va être confronté à une
situation a priori est terrible dans les
jours qui viennent projections sont
assez catastrophique effectivement oui
julien aubert alors vous êtes dans la
position de l'opposant est ce que c'est
pas un peu facile du coup parce que vous
votre parti en tout cas soutient ces
petits commerçants dans leur fronde
est-ce que c'est pas une prise de risque
politique de votre part est ce que c'est
un comportement
on peut qualifier de responsables quand
on voit la crise sanitaire qui qui est
là ça dépend ce qu'on appelle se tenir
dans la fronde
clairement il ya deux sujets un peu
d'abord le sujet sanitaire effectivement
de savoir s'il fallait ou faire ou pas
un confinement
certains pays ont fait des choix
différents sur doute qu'il ya un
problème sur le livre et animations et
que c'est là la solution finalement la
plus stupide parce qu'elle est la plus
facile qui est de maintenir tout le
monde à la maison
on pourrait d'ailleurs d'assad est à se
demander si c'est un vrai confinement ou
un semis confinement parce qu'il est
quand même assez différent du premier
mais ce qui est aussi le cas dans nos
chez nos voisins y compris en mode plus
léger en fait si vous voulez qu'on vous
regarde effectivement paris qui est très
concentré en service en bureau où les
gens font du télétravail effectivement
on a l'impression d'être dans un une
ville confiné quand vous allez dans des
villes où il ya moins d'activités de
service et très peu de télétravail de
les russes ont quand même tout aussi
active que d'habitude mais ensuite il va
venir dont on a pensé la philosophie du
confinement
moi je conteste pas si vous voulez
l'idée d'avoir un confinement néanmoins
je crois que la distinction entre
activités essentielles et non essentiels
pour justifier les fermetures est une
une idée qui ne fonctionne pas d'abord
parce que pour celui qui est fermé il a
l'impression que quelque part il est
entre guillemets moins utiles à la
nation d'accord donc par exemple
effectivement le divertissement le
frivole un cabaret un théâtre etc
ça peut sembler superflu entre
guillemets mais c'est le coeur d'une
activité économique également
et puis deuxièmement parce qu'après on
rentre dans des sujets d'inégalités
c'est à dire qu'effectivement vous allez
avoir des gens qui sont fermés d'autres
qui sont ouverts alors que la seule
règle qui vaille
si je reprends d'ailleurs
l'argumentation de mon collègue c'est le
risque sanitaire est donc je pense qu'on
aurait dû davantage basés les fermetures
sur l'existence ou pas d'un risque
sanitaire avéré
est ce que vous êtes capable de mettre
en place un protocole sanitaire qui
protège vos clients oui vous êtes ouvert
si vous n'êtes pas capable dans ce cas
là effectivement c'est fermé parce que
la conséquence de tout ça c'est que du
coup vous avez un manque d'adhésion et
un sentiment d'injustice et il est
normal car septembre d'élus se fassent
les porte-voix de ce sentiment
d'injustice alors effectivement comme
vous l'avez pointé
fermé pour tout le monde c'est je dirais
stupide dans le sang sur tout le monde
perd mais en même temps il faut
s'imaginer aussi que celui qui est fermé
mais qui voit sa clientèle captée par le
voisin lui considère qu'il ya une
inégalité ferait donc ouais c'est même
légalement il ya un déséquilibre de
conquête voilà donc si vous voulez après
on a su et d'amazon derrière qui est un
sujet plus vaste qui est bien antérieure
au confinement
ok tu as encore un autre sujet mais en
tout cas je pense si vous voulez que il
ya deux défauts dans ce confinement
1 la distinction essentielle donnée
essentielle et 2 le fait qu'on a fait un
t-shirt m pour tout le monde
du coup il ya des endroits où on est
boudinés et des endroits où on flotte
dans le t-shirt j'ai d'abord vous et que
vous avez sentiments vous que le critère
du risque sanitaire a pas été prises en
compte dans la décision de laisser
ouvert ou fermé certains magasins mais
au contraire il sous-tend toute la
politique que l'on est en train de
mettre en place
d'abord je voulais revenir très
rapidement sur l'histoire des lits de
l'animation entendu beaucoup parler de
ce sujet des lits de réanimation
on va y consacrer toute une partie de
l'émission tout à l'heure si tu es
quelque chose c'était accès pas l'alpha
et l'oméga des décisions politiques
si vous voulez la question c'est
d'éviter que les gens qu'ils soient
contaminés je vous rappelle juste à
titre d'exemple que 30% des personnes
qui rentrent en réanimation vont mourir
quel que soit le nombre de lits de
réanimation donc je pense que c'est
quand même à prendre en considération ça
veut dire qu'il faut éviter les
contaminations
d'autre part moi je pense que j'étais
pour engorger l'hôpital je pense que non
justement
messieurs je croyais quand vous êtes à
financer le discours moi je croyais
dyson confiné pour andré gilles mendel
l'hôpital je vous ai écouté calmement
séjour il souffrait en silence mais je
pars là bas mais c'est vraiment se
focaliser sur la question des six
commerçants sur les petits commerces moi
je pense que votre position elle est
irresponsable et mensongères d'abord
pourquoi les mensonges heures parce que
ça n'est absolument pas une
stigmatisation de telle ou telle de tel
ou tel protocole sanitaire chez un
commerçant
qu'est-ce qu'on sous-tendant cette
décision là c'est éviter autant que
faire se peut le fait qu'il y ait plus
de multiples allers retours va et vient
d'un commerce à l'autre des passages sur
les trottoirs dans l'espace public on ne
remet pas en cause le protocole
sanitaire des commerçants absolument pas
nous n'avons rien contre les commerçants
évidemment ça c'est le premier point est
irresponsable pourquoi parce que vous
embarquer les commerces
dans un débat qui me paraît
particulièrement mensonges et vous les
utiliser à des fins politiques pourquoi
je vous dis ça rit ça parce que si
demain nous réouvre ont tous les
commerces
je vous dire une chose vous allez faire
perdre à tous ces commerces les aides
puisqu'à partir du moment où les
réouvrir inéluctablement
nous considérons qu'il n'y a plus besoin
d'être puisqu'ils veulent travailler
très bien sauf que je vais où il ya une
chose si demain on les résoudre d'abord
ça difficile parce que vous êtes en
train de remettre en question en
confinement parce que si on les réseaux
il va falloir on va tous pouvoir aller
dans tous les commerces et puis d'autre
part ils n'auront personne pas de
clients parce que il n'ya pas de
consommation je vous parle un exemple
très concret et ça a dû vous arrivez
dans votre circonscription rapidement et
après on va aller voir les pâtissiers
les chocolatiers qui me dit s'il vous
plaît monsieur le député vous nous
voudrions ne plus être dans les
commerces dits essentiels parce que nous
ne vendons pas de chocolat pas de gâteau
et nous n'avons pas droit aux aides
donc c'est la double peine donc il va
falloir qu'on soit capable de légiférer
là dessus et de prendre des décisions
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que demain réouvre ont tous les
commerces les gens vont vendre une paire
de chaussures dans la journée n'auront
plus droit aux aides aide qui je le
rappelle c'est que j'adore mais nous
mettons sur la joie attendait dans sa
remarque c'est que plutôt que de faire
ce choix essentiels dont l'essentiel on
voit bien que c'est très difficile de le
faire on voit pas une règle en dix ans
on a droit à quatre mètres carrés par
personne
c'est ce que nous faisons dans ce cas la
grande distribution dans ce cas pourquoi
ne pas appliquer cette même règle à
n'importe quel commerce s'il un coiffeur
est capable d'assurer qu'il ya quatre
mètres carrés pour chacun de ses clients
pourquoi on ne voudra pas parce que tout
simplement il ne vous aura pas échappé
on a souvent cité l'espagne comme comme
exemple en disant ils sont plutôt axés
sur les petits commerces parce que cela
fait vingt ans trente ans que tout
majorités politiques confondues et même
les citoyens nous avons largement
consommée et privilégier les
hypermarchés supermarchés
c'est un fait c'est comme ça aujourd'hui
si vous voulez aller faire des courses
dites essentielles ou les frais dans un
seul endroit
c'est le supermarché l'hypermarché or
ces sessions réécouter on va on va
écouter la parole des commerçants tout
de même pas ce que c'est les premiers
intéressés
nous sommes en liaison vidéo avec lionel
saugues dont vous êtes vice président de
la fédération française des commerçants
de france
vous avez été par ailleurs membre de la
république en marche dans la ville de
saint-etienne ce que je préfère le
préciser avant avant d'ouvrir le débat
qu'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement aujourd'hui
bonjour à toutes et à tous
merci pour cette invitation alors vous
dira en préambule que les commerçants de
notre pays ont conscience de la
situation sanitaire que connaît notre
pays et qui est particulièrement
alarmante et je vais vous dire aussi que
ils ont été particulièrement exemplaire
quant à la gestion de cette crise lors
du premier confinement il faut en avoir
conscience
les commerçants ont fait respecter les
barrières ils ont parfois fait la police
au sein au sein de leur boutique
donc cette prise de conscience elle est
lé real après pour autant vous
l'imaginez vous l'avez très bien
expliqué tout à l'heure nos commerçants
sont sous le choc sont en colère face
aux mesures qui ont été annoncées
récemment à la fois par le président de
la république et le premier ministre
parce que il faut vous ayez en tête que
nous connaissons maintenant depuis deux
ans une situation véritablement
dramatique pour nos entreprises du
commerce avec d'abord une crise sociale
avec c'est une multitude de
manifestations autour des gis légende
que nous avons connue ce contexte
sécuritaire extrêmement difficile dans
lequel est plongé notre pays
et puis une première vague de
confinement qui a été très dure et qui a
mis à genoux beaucoup de nos commerçants
indépendants qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent sans trésorerie et donc à
cela s'ajoute maintenant cette deuxième
vague qui tombe simplement au plus mal
oui et alors il ya tout un système dead
qui a été mise en place tout de même
pour vous pour en tout cas les commerces
qui sont contraints de fermer mais vous
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous attendez concrètement
du gouvernement sur cette question des
commerces non essentiels on attend déjà
il faut reconnaître que le gouvernement
bruno le maire à l'église et notamment
ont été ont été la découpe des
commerçants avec la mobilisation de
l'état clairement à hauteur de 20
milliards d'euros je le rappelle à effet
a été très forte et il faut s'en
féliciter
après malheureusement pour beaucoup de
commerçants cela ne sera pas suffisant
et beaucoup d'entre eux vont mourir dans
les prochains mois et dépendantes
et de notre économie de proximité va
disparaître avec les conséquences que
l'on connaît sur sur nos centres villes
et nos centres bourgs qui sont des gens
en difficulté depuis depuis déjà
plusieurs mois donc clairement on attend
on attend plusieurs choses on attend de
mettre fin définitivement à cette
concurrence déloyale qu'on a beaucoup
évoqué vis-à-vis de la grande
distribution des mesures ont été prises
on s'en félicite très clairement reste
la problématique la concurrence déloyale
qui exercent les grandes plateformes de
e-commerce à l'image d'amazon qui est
aujourd'hui un vrai problème est qu'il
sera encore plus demain
je rappelle que amazon a pour projet
d'implanter une dizaine d'entrepôts dans
les prochaines années
à l'échelle de la france dont deux sur
la région auvergne rhône-alpes dieu
nordique et à proximité de la
circonscription de julien aubert à deux
pas du pont du gard donc c'est dire
l'impact et le développement fort qui
est attendu sur ses comptes à fin dans
les prochaines années et on attend
clairement de la part du gouvernement
des mesures extrêmement fortes sur ce
sujet et un accompagnement aussi dans la
numérisation nécessaire des commerçants
indépendants et vous restez avec nous on
va on va voir à présent que les
commerçants les petits commerçants ont
reçu un soutien de poids dans leur
fronde le soutien de nombreux maires ils
sont plus d'une cinquantaine à avoir
pris des arrêtés alors des arrêtés qui
sont illégaux pour autoriser justement
les commerces non essentiels à à ouvrir
certains vont même plus loin un ca à
puce et dans l'essonne le maire a lancé
un appel aux trois coiffeurs de sa
commune pour qu'ils ouvrent leur
commerce et donc ils désobéissent à
l'état c'est un reportage de maïté
frémont et cléa jouanno c'est un arrêté
municipal afin d'autoriser maintien de
l'ouverture des salons de coiffure a pu
faire avec ce bout de papier c'est
maintenant écrit noir sur blanc le
décret qui oblige les coiffeurs affirmé
grégory courtat n'en veut pas dans son
village
ils ont respecté à la lettre tout ce
qu'on leur a demandé ils ont investi
mais on vous fait tout leur trésorerie
pour justement respecter les règles 2
hygiène et sanitaires et je peux vous
dire c'est pas là le gérer 6e le
développement dans les salons de
coiffure autrement il faut faut me le
dire et on leur dit demain vous faire
les gregory courtat est maire depuis 12
ans à puce et de 1200 habitants
ici il y a une dizaine de commerces dont
trois coiffeurs pour garder le dynamisme
de son village le maire est prêt à
réouvrir les salons mais aucun des
coiffeurs ne souhaite prendre le risque
non on n'a pas décidé de rester ouvertes
pourquoi parce que s'ils demain en ur et
qu'on a un contrôle de la gendarmerie
on est en cours quand même une amende de
135 euros et six mois de fermeture
administrative
donc il ya déjà ampleur pour une
fermeture d'amour alors six mois enfin
faut même pas faux même pas rêver quoi
jennifer a ouvert son salon il y a tout
juste un an
aujourd'hui elle ne veut qu'une seule
chose je vais travailler je veux je veux
pouvoir vivre correctement et et avoir
une vie digne d'une vie n'est pas dans
l'égalité voilà j'ai jamais été dans
l'inégalité c'est pas aujourd'hui je
vais commencer
nous on meurt pas par la maladie mais on
meurt par le manque de travail et donc
le manque de recettes à la fin du mans
les sauver coûte que coûte
grégory courtat à une dernière cartouche
pour les convaincre moi j'ai proposé
même les commerçants d'ouvrir et vous
vous retournez contre l'arrêté du maire
et vous l'attaquez au tribunal
d'instance administratif pardon de
versailles c'est très bien que le décret
c'est un document supra communal qui est
bien au dessus d'un arrêté municipal
mais il ya aussi du bon sens et la
désobéissance
on va dire civique en tout cas de ma
part des sceaux décence républicaine
plutôt plus précisément malgré la
désobéissance républicaine de nombreux
élus la préfecture de l'essonne continue
à être ferme sur sa décision
depuis le début du confinement cinq
arrêtés municipaux étaient en
contradiction manifeste avec ce décret
il exposait plus les commerçants qu'ils
ne les protège et tout s'est arrêté ont
été déférés au tribunal administratif et
le premier ministre a réagi cet après
midi à l'assemblée à ces quelques maires
1 qui lancent des appels à la
désobéissance civile vous allez le voir
jean castex est très en colère quand la
situation exige des mesures courageuses
et nécessaires
quand la république quand la république
est confronté à la plus grave crise
sanitaire qu'elle ait subie depuis des
décennies on n'appelle pas les mères
serviteur de la république a violé les
lois de la république
les bains possible
ils ne s'y sont pas trompés ils ne s'y
sont pas trompés seuls 71 d'entre eux
ont pris un arrêté 16 l'ont retirée
alors johnny aubert c'est la première
fois qu'on voit jean castex se met en
colère comme ça depuis qu'il est premier
ministre
est-ce que vous soutenez vous
personnellement ces appels lancés par
quelques maires ses appels à la
désobéissance civile je pense si vous
voulez que ça a permis de bien bouger
les choses que c'était des lanceurs
dallaire tous que ça reflète un malaise
après une fois que le gouvernement a
pris des mesures on peut pas basculer
dans l'illégalité
sachant que ces arrêtés effectivement
sont illégaux maintenant je maintiens
que tout le discours du gouvernement est
basé sur une pseudo
je dirais analyses scientifiques avec le
même aplomb qu'on avait lorsqu'on
expliquer qu'on n'avait pas besoin du
masque il ya six mois et donc à ceux ci
les gens opposent leur bon sens consiste
à dire moi je suis coiffeur je peux
recevoir un client toutes les
demi-heures laissez moi travailler et ça
on aura beau m'expliquer tout ce qu'on
veut on n'arrivera pas à convaincre de
la légitimité de cette manière de
fonctionner si c'est contraire au bon
sens c'est pour ça d'ailleurs j'ai lancé
une pétition qui s'appelle ma proximité
est essentielle parce que je pense que
beaucoup de français
en fait on peur vous disiez tout à
l'heure la grande surface à manger les
petits commerces donc c'est pour ça
qu'on voulait les grandes surfaces et
c'est pour ça que je défends les petits
commerces
parce que là vous avez définitivement
les tuer je viens bronzer que juste les
maires des lanceurs d'alerté selon vous
pour reprendre les termes de julien
aubert 1 je pense qu'ils ont été une
fois de plus emmené dans une dans une
polémique politicienne
et que je trouve totalement
irresponsable je le maintiens ce genre
de pétition géante dans le but c'est pas
d'opposer les gens les uns aux autres et
on va pouvoir on peut on peut aussi
lancer une pétition avec les soignants
qui vont vous liam sur verre et à un
moment donné on aimerait essayer de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient un peu moins
de gens qui arrivent dans nos hôpitaux
mais la seconde est dans une situation
sanitaire grave on l'oubli un petit peu
mais aussi sachant combien ce soit les
allées à l'hôpital allait voir les
soignants je crois qu'ils ont besoin
aussi qu'on les soutienne les hauts
risques de contamination il est majoré
lorsqu on casse le confinement c'est ce
que vous proposez non c'est une pression
va donner le mot de la fin à lionel sauf
si vous voulez bien pour voir justement
comment vous vous positionnez vous
qu'est-ce que vous conseiller aux
commerçants qui sont dans des communes
où les mères leur dise bavaisis ouvrez
ouvrez on vient voir qui risque quand
même une fermeture administrative de six
mois parce que ce que je voulais tout
d'abord c'était salué le courage de tous
ces maires qui ont qui ont rappelé
l'importance du commerce de proximité
l'échelle de notre pays je rappellerai
que président de la république et le
premier ministre ont ont indiqué que
cette deuxième phase de confinement ne
devait pas mettre à mal notre économie
je rappellerai simplement que le
commerce en france et 900 mille
entreprises et 3 millions d'emplois
donc le commerce c'est aussi et avant
tout un acteur économique de premier x
qui fait vivre nos territoires
ça c'est le premier point mais je
voulais aussi dire aux élus vous
répondez pas à la question sur qu'est ce
que voulaient au commerçant qu'est ce
que vous dites aux commerçants dont les
maires les appelle à ouvrir leurs
boutiques malgré tout nous avons enfin
je ne suis pas sûr clairement que ces
arrêtés même si comme julien robert l'a
dit ça a permis de mettre le focus sur
la situation à les faire changer des
prises de position du gouvernement
pour autant ce n'est pas la situation
clairement ce n'est pas la solution
bardon et moi j'attends la part des élus
locaux comme beaucoup d'acteurs du
commerce qu'ils puissent activer leurs
leviers économiques fiscaux qui sont
nombreux en termes d'exonérations de
taxes de droits de voirie ne taxe sur la
publicité de cotisation foncière sur les
entreprises et levier des collectivités
locales ce soit l'aide pour les mères
pour les présidents d'agglomérations de
métropole goût pour les présidents de
région sont nombreux
et clairement si tous les élus
souhaitent soutenir notre commerce
indépendant en particulier il est urgent
d'activer l'ensemble de ces leviers aux
côtés aux côtés de l'état qui a fait
beaucoup et puis une dernière seconde un
dernier message c'est surtout nous avons
besoin de rapidement ré ouvrir nos
activités commerciales parce que nos
commerçants ne comprennent pas
effectivement que nos grandes surfaces
soit ouvert et que nos petits commerces
soit merci à vous lionel somme merci
julien aubert d'être venu sur le plateau
de ça vous regarde aussi pour pour
débattre de tout cela vous restez avec
nous unir bozic parce que dans un
instant on va on va débattre du volet
sanitaire de cette crise mais d'abord un
coup de projecteur sur un sujet qui a
agité l'assemblée aujourd'hui et qui est
en lien avec cette crise sanitaire
l'éventuel rétablissement d'un
couvre-feu qui viendrait s'ajouter au
confinement à paris bonjour thomas des
prêts oui bonsoir clément c'est le couac
de la journée y aura-t-il un couvre-feu
en plus du confinement à paris et en
région parisienne
le sujet a fait beaucoup débat parmi les
députés aujourd'hui je vous raconte tout
ça c'est ma journée à l'assemblée alors
c'était ce matin sur bfm gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement était
l'invité de la matinale pour répondre
aux questions de jean jacques bourdin
sur l'épidémie et il a fait une annonce
que personne n'attendait
nous allons
ré instaurer un couvre-feu sur paris
peut-être ile de france c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il précisera
dans la journée on arrêtait va sortir
précisément pour limiter un couvre-feu à
paris a eu comme il ya eu avant que le
confinement soir en plus en plus de ce
nouveau confinement sur quelle heure le
couvre-feu à 21h je crois comme
le couvent rosso qui avaient lu avant le
confinant alors dans la bouche de
gabriella talent cette annonce devait
être faite dans la journée oui mais
voilà du côté de matignon n'est pas du
tout sur cette même ligne
des journalistes ont été contactés par
les services du premier ministre une
décision pas décidé à l'heure actuelle
une décision qui sera prise dans les
prochains jours ont-ils indiqué oui mais
voilà le mal était déjà fait il a parlé
trop vite
gabriella talent ce matin moi je crois
qu'il faut être très humble par rapport
à ce virus qui bouscule beaucoup des
habitudes qui sont les autres d'un point
de vue politique de communication
sanitaire d'organisation de l'état et
donc on voit bien que la propagation de
l'épidémie se poursuit dans notre pays
et il est naturel que en répondant aux
questions des journalistes le porte
parole du gouvernement puissent émettre
certaines réflexions sur les mesures qui
pourraient être à prendre
on a le sentiment que ce gouvernement
est en permanence en défensive
coincé dans le coin du ring à prendre
des décisions de manière urgente
sans concertation sans réflexion les
prendre ir venir puis les reprendre vous
refais pas couvre-feu confinement à quel
niveau petits commerces etc
c'est n'importe quoi il faut de la
cohérence il faut de la clarté
là on a le sentiment que c'est kafka à
la tête du pouvoir kafka la tête du
pouvoir c'est la technocratie permanente
et la technocratie permanente c'est
l'échec assuré des confidences ce
gouvernement ne gouverne le pays
je pense que c'est le conseil de défense
voulu par monsieur macron désigné par
monsieur macro organisé par monsieur
macro qui prend les décisions ça fait
pas un peu amateur
alors si être modeste par rapport à
l'évolution quotidienne du virus qui on
le voit il ya dix jours ne devait pas
être aussi grave que ce que c'est prévu
maintenant alors si c'est ça oui on est
amateur mais franchement aujourd'hui je
crois qu'on les fasse du mieux qu'on
peut
je répète encore une fois la situation
sanitaire évolué et donc la
réglementation doit évoluer en fonction
de la situation sanitaire voilà clément
demain matin c'est un conseil de défense
à l'elysée autour d' emmanuel macron qui
devrait à décider s'il faut remettre ou
non un couvre-feu à paris on suivra dans
les prochains jours et on suivra cela
avec vous évidemment thomas le
professeur alexandre mebazaa nous a
rejoint bonsoir vous êtes responsable du
service de réanimation à l'hôpital saint
louis à paris ans
blanc va évoquer à présent justement le
volet sanitaire de cette crise et cette
question les hôpitaux vont-ils tenir
face à cette seconde vague s'annonce
encore plus haute que la première c'est
notre décryptage
[Musique]
quels que soient les effets du
confinement il y a une certitude les
quinze jours qui viennent vont être très
difficiles dans les hôpitaux ils vont
subir une sans doute nous tension qui
sera sans doute supérieure à celle de la
de la première vague une des clés pour
tenir le choc ça va être la capacité du
système hospitalier a augmenté le nombre
de lits de réanimation
beaucoup de chiffres sont différents ont
circulé sur ce sujet alors qu'en est il
exactement des capacités de la france la
réponse avec hélène bonduelle et ras aby
cas l'enjeu est crucial alors que
l'épidémie flambe le nombre de lits
disponibles en réanimation fait l'objet
de toutes les attentions
de combien de lits de réanimation la
france dispose t-elle la france ne
dispose que de 5800 les en réanimation
pourtant début avril au plus fort de
l'épidémie sept mille lits avaient pu
être mobilisé en même temps une équation
rendue possible grâce au report des
opérations chirurgicales et à la
conversion de certaines unités de soins
en service de réanimation
la france est elle en capacité d'ouvrir
plus de lits de réanimation
optimiste le ministre de la santé a
assuré il ya quelques jours que douze
mille lits de réanimation serait
mobilisables en cas de deuxième vague
alors que la situation épidémique est
aujourd'hui critique
le président de la république n'avance
plus que le chiffre de dix mille lits
soit 2002 - mais le premier ministre l'a
assuré ce matin les stocks de
respirateurs masques et médicaments sont
suffisants pour prendre en charge
trente mille malades qu'ovide en
réanimation au lieu de 17 mille lors de
la première vague
quid du personnel
qui dit les de réanimation du personnel
soignant mais les hôpitaux français
manquent de bras
pour y remédier le gouvernement mise sur
une revalorisation salariale et le
recrutement de 15000 personnes dans les
hôpitaux
et si la situation française est souvent
mise en parallèle avec le modèle
allemand
il est difficile de comparer les deux
pays à première vue avec ses vingt mille
lits de réanimation
l'allemagne fait mieux que l'hexagone
mais le mode de calcul n'est pas le même
les lits de réanimation en france
répondent à des normes bien plus
contraignante qu'en allemagne professeur
mebazaa d'abord on vient de voir un ces
chiffres 10 mille lits de réanimation
potentiel on va dire en france
concrètement on fait comment pour armer
c'est le terme qu'on emploie dans le
milieu hospitalier pour armer un lit de
réanimation se fait au détriment de quoi
de qui
avec quel matériel et quel personnel
alors aujourd'hui les le périmètre est
élargie parce que en plus des
réanimation médicale polyvalente et
chirurgical on a ce qu'on appelle les
soins continue ses soins continus n'ont
normalement pas de ventilateur donc en
train de les armer en matériel c'est à
dire ventilateur seringues 5 électrique
et le personnel qui est exactement celui
qui lie à en réanimation il ya ce qu'on
appelle les salles de réveil comment va
diminuer les blocs opératoires les
salles qui permet renoncer à des
interventions chirurgicales sur d'autres
patients donc au vide exactement pour en
reparler mais c'est un vrai drame pour
les gens qui ne sont pas qu'au vide
néanmoins ce périmètre là il est repris
là de la même manière c'est donc on met
des ventilateurs on met des des
seringues électrique du matériel et en
armes en personnel et ce personnel
évidemment c'est du personnel qui sort
du bloc opératoire c'est du personnel
quitter dans d'autres services qu'on est
en train de fermer et on a suffisamment
de personnel pour pouvoir gérer ces lits
de réanimation en tout cas aujourd'hui
le plan c'est de refaire un peu ce qu'on
a fait la première vague donc le
personnel certes il ya eu des aides etc
mais aujourd'hui on doit pouvoir armer
ses 10000 ses dix mille lits ils sont
atteignables vous y croyez c'est un
objectif politique ou c'est une réalité
à portée de main non c'est une réalité
qu'on doit pouvoir atteindre le score on
voit quand même le gros avantage qu'on a
pendant cette deuxième vague qu'on
n'avait pas la première vague c'est que
pendant la première vague
d'abord personne n'y a cru
souvenez on a dit les italiens et
c'était vraiment fait l'italie avait
fait un très très bon job est allé très
vite
cette fois ci on est plutôt sur une
marée montante on prend son temps et ça
nous laisse le temps de mettre en place
les médicaments qui nous avait un peu
manqué tout le matériel pour bien se
protéger et de remettre en place qu'on
avait mis en place la première fois je
veux dire bravo et qu'alors vous vous
êtes pas seulement député j'ai envie de
dire vous êtes aussi médecin vous êtes
élus de ce département de la loire qui
est le plus touché aujourd'hui qui va
être confronté à une situation sans
précédent le système hospitalier est il
prêt à faire face selon vous à cette
vague aujourd'hui qui s'annonce plus
haute que la première voyais
effectivement j'ai fait un point cet
après midi avec les responsables du chu
en anesthésie-réanimation les
urgentistes avec la directrice adjointe
à saint-etienne à saint-etienne mais on
nous annonce effectivement dans les
quinze jours qui viennent selon les
projections un doublement du nombre de
personnes en réanimation passé de 90 à
180 en a fait un point et oui les
capacités sont là sont prêtes pour
accueillir tous ces patients entendu
certains maires qui demandaient des
hôpitaux militaires absolument pas
besoin on est capable d'absorber dans
des conditions c'est parce que dit
l'institut pasteur dans les projections
dont le monde s'est fait l'écho hier il
évoquait la possibilité que 350 patients
dans la région auvergne rhône-alpes ne
puisse pas être accueillis en service de
réanimation vu les capacités de
d'armement si l'on peut dire des
hôpitaux
je moi je vous réponds sur sur la loi de
manière assez précise et factuelle
puisque ce sont les chiffres dont je
dispose
c'est vrai que pour reprendre ce qu'est
ce qui vient d'être dit on a cette
chance entre guillemets que la marée
monte progressivement et on a fait
beaucoup de transferts intra régionaux
et surtout extra régionaux en
particulier de saint-etienne vers
bordeaux pour justement soulagé avant
même d'être un taux un taux plein donc
aujourd'hui d'après les projections et
d'après ce que l'on a mis en place par
place qu'ils ont mis en place sur le chu
de saint-etienne il surtout que j'ai
acheté le groupe hôpital territoire on
peut absorber selon les projections de
l'institut pasteur
mais inéluctablement c'est quand même
une marée montante énorme et est pire en
tout la sur notre région que la première
vague alors on va on va essayer d'y voir
plus clair sur la situation actuelle
justement ouest condamné précisé
de cette épidémie on va poser la
question avec guillaume rozier qui est
en liaison en visioconférence avec nous
bonsoir donc vous êtes statisticiens
vous avez créé ce site qui est de plus
en plus consultés à parler français
qu'ovide tracts tracker qui permet de
suivre au jour le jour l'évolution de
l'épidémie d'abord première question est
ce qu'avec l'ensemble des données que
vous que vous brassez que vous récoltez
vous êtes en mesure de prédire le pic la
date à laquelle il surviendra et le
niveau qu'atteindra se pique de cette
seconde vague alors je ne peux pas
prédire la date du pic tout simplement
parce que ça va dépendre de nos
comportements de dépend du comportement
des gens actuellement
par contre ce qu'on peut prévoir c'est
comment vont évoluer les chiffres dans
les prochains jours et actuellement on a
une croissance qui est exponentielle qui
est stable depuis depuis plusieurs jours
et qui est exponentielle donc par
exemple on peut indiquer que le nombre
de personnes hospitalisées pour l'aco
vide aura dépassé le nombre spécialisés
de copie de la première vague et 10,6 à
peu près deux à trois jours et c'est à
peu près pareil pour les réanimations
d'ici d'ici quelques jours en d'ici une
semaine on va dépasser le nombre de
personnes qui est en réanimation lors de
la première vague et met donc on peut
pas prévoir avec précision la date du
deuxième pic est ce que dans l'est dans
vos statistiques vous percevez les
premiers effets des mesures qui ont été
prises il ya deux semaines un peu plus
maintenant avec notamment ce couvre-feu
qui avait été établi dans plusieurs
grandes métropoles françaises
alors c'est extrêmement délicat puisque
on observe une stabilisation voire une
baisse du nombre de cas sur l'ensemble
du territoire mais notamment dans les 22
métropoles françaises
alors c'est très délicat on sait pas si
cette baisse alors d'abord cette baisse
elle est peut-être pas réel tout
simplement parce qu'on observe un retard
dans le traitement des données et ces
données d'après mes informations
pourraient être rectifiée dans les
prochains jours donc il se pourrait que
la baisse sont un trompe l'oeil d'une
part et d'autre part c'est très
difficile de savoir si cette baisse si
elle est réelle donc si elle est due à
nos vacances au couvre-feu ou à d'autres
facteurs externes docteur mebazaa quand
vous entendez ça vous vous dites quoi on
a confiné trop tard en tout cas il ya
quand même un point que nos concitoyens
doivent comprendre c'est que certes yali
chiffres il ya le nombre de malades
et on a dit roddick eu là j'étais à peu
près le même que c'était des facteurs de
précarité mais que la sévérité et quand
même pas la même
aujourd'hui en réanimation les malades
qu'on reçoit n'ont pas la même sévérité
que ce que on a vu pendant la première
vague et tous les rénovateurs français
et tous les rythmes açores européens
sont d'accord avec çà tient coi une
meilleure prise en charge thérapeutique
on ne sait pas encore scientifiquement à
quoi c'est dû mais le bon sens voudrait
parce que quand même on parle aux
malades quand ils arrivent on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il arrive beaucoup plus
tôt qu'ils n'arrivaient pendant la
première vague
je vous rappelle que le colis de la
difficulté c'est que le malade il a la
fièvre
ensuite ils y croient ils pensent que ça
va bien donc il va pas consulté la
fréquence respiratoire qui est quand
même un très bon déterminant reste
constante est stable et normale pendant
très longtemps et c'est uniquement quand
il va mal qui se sent mal qu'il appelle
et ça ça prend des jours et des jours
aujourd'hui le message à faire passer
c'est quand vous avez de la fièvre
allez vite voir mettre votre médecin
généraliste d'abord ça peut être une
petite grippe entre guillemets et pas le
coc vide et si c'est le cas ou vic bilh
vous surveillera de très très près et on
a aujourd'hui grâce aux saturomètre
grâce à votre état on a des moyens de
faire vite rentrer ces malades est
aujourd'hui clairement tous les
réanimateurs vous disent que la sévérité
moindre et donc bah on arrive à tenir
ces malades et donc donc on peut c'est
pour ça qu'on peut accepter un nombre un
peu plus élevé que la dernière fois sans
que ce soit nécessairement la
catastrophe
un mot encore avec vous guillaume rosir
je sais vous faites vos statistiques
aussi en étudiant des situations plus
local est ce que par exemple vous pouvez
nous dire que à l'heure actuelle vu le
nombre de cas qui sont déclarés dans la
loire est ce qu'on peut savoir qu'elle
va l'être le nombre de personnes
accueillies en réanimation dans ce
département qui est vraiment dans une
situation critique
oui alors tout à fait j'ai pas les
chiffres en tête donc j'invite les
téléspectateurs à se rendre sur kobe
tracker point fr et puis aller voir
directement dans la loire quels sont les
chiffres et comment ils vont évoluer et
et puis surtout il ya un autre paramètre
à prendre en compte c'est le transfert
de patient puisque j'imagine que des
patients sont transférés vers d'autres
hôpitaux dans d'autres départements de
qu'actuellement on a un taux de
saturation de des réanimations dans la
loire qui est supérieur à 100 % par
rapport aux chiffres par rapport au
nombre de lits
disponible en réanimation en temps
normal mais donc j'imagine que des lits
supplémentaires ont dû être ouvert et
que des transferts de patients ont été
effectués vers d'autres hôpitaux
merci qu'on va pouvoir en faire encore
des montants des transferts de patients
ailleurs en france parce que le la
caractéristique de cette seconde vague
c'est qu'elle touche tout le pays
bien sûr la question si vous voulez c
était vraiment entre le siège suit la rs
de pouvoir travailler en amont pour
essayer d'éviter la saturation et
surtout la fatigue immédiate des
personnels donc on pourra continuer à en
faire mais on a développé un certain
nombre on a déployé à sa forme de lit
donc pour l'instant honnêtement la
situation je vais pas vous dire qu'elle
est sous contrôle parce que c'est très
difficile de vous le dire qu'elle est
sous contrôle mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant pour en avoir discuté vraiment
avec les professionnels de terrain
je vais vous dire une chose il était
peut-être un peu moins paniqués je
dirais qu'il ya une semaine ou dix jours
je mets vraiment beaucoup de guillemets
là dedans et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
semaine ou dix jours on a vu une
explosion des cas partout dans le
département
c'est vrai qu'on avait la métropole
stéphanoise qui était ciblé au départ
est très rapidement du tout le
département et j ai la situation la pire
parce que nous n'arrivions pas à trouver
un cluster un foyer c'était partout tous
les âges toutes catégories
socioprofessionnelles et c'est ça qui
nous a inquiétés avec des chiffres qui
montrent est énormément
juste une petite chose parce que je
crois qu'il faut en faire un petit peu
la publicité on est en train de déployer
sur le département et on est un peu
pilote là dessus le fait de prendre en
charge les patients en service de soins
l'adaptation nécessaire mais plutôt que
se faisait avant puisqu'en général est
nécessaire voulait que les patients une
pcr négative pour sortir et donc
maintenant on va essayer de prendre en
charge tout de suite et pour baisser la
durée moyenne de séjour de deux jours ce
qui est énorme pour soulager les
hôpitaux mais on va le faire avec la
médecine de ville
c'est assez innovant et je pense qu'on
devrait arriver à de belles solutions
comme ça et on envoie le déployer sur
tout le terrain j'espère le mot de la
fin pour vous professeur mebazaa vous
êtes confiant optimistes pour les jours
qui viennent alors premièrement il faut
redire aux concitoyens que le virus
tourne tourne tourne à fond ça s'est il
faut le dire et le répéter
ai je vraiment je vous félicite d'avoir
demandé à ce qu'on vienne tous avec un
masque parce que c'est des symboles qui
sont très importants et ces deux minutes
de baisse de masques qui fait
que le quelqu'un de normal devient
malade ça c'est très très important
deuxièmement il ya j'ai jamais vu un
engouement aussi fort pour une maladie
tout le monde ait la main dans la main
les chiffres sont regardés vraiment
millimètre par millimètre est vraiment
la france d'abord les français sont
héroïques je le dis je le répète et la
france aujourd'hui elle est prête à voir
les marges arrivé et on ne sera pas sous
l'eau on saura exactement quoi faire le
bon moment merci à tous les deux je vous
donne juste les chiffres qui viennent
d'être donnés sur les contaminations
d'aujourd'hui trente six mille nouveaux
cas aujourd'hui contre 52 milliards on
ne peut évidemment pas en tirer de
conclusions
ils vous regardent et cela sur la durée
pour voir et évidemment l'évolution des
cours merci à vous messieurs on quitte
la france à présent direction les
états-unis dernières heures de vote donc
pour les américains pour élire alors
leur prochain président richard verdi et
en direct avec nous depuis philadelphie
en pennsylvanie
c'est l'un des swing states comme on dit
un de ces états qui peut décider du sort
de cette élection et la ville de
philadelphie richard se prépare au pire
la population a peur de ce qui pourrait
se produire dans les heures qui vont
suivre l'annoncé des résultats alors
effectivement c'est très frappant ici
c'est la peur et l'anxiété qui domine
d'ailleurs l'anxiété c'est un mot qui
revient quasiment dans tous les journaux
américains il y en a 2 derrière moi
c'est cette inquiétude devant ce qu'il
peut se passer une fois que les urnes
vont être close c'est à dire à 20 heures
et là il faudra entamer le dépouillement
à la fois des gens qui sont venus voter
pendant la journée et les files sont
très longues j'ai pu le constater ce
matin ici à philadelphie où je me trouve
mais il faudra aussi dépouillé tous les
autres votes c'est à dire les fameux
vote anticipé qui ont été déposés dans
les urnes avant la date du 3 novembre
c'est possible dans un certain nombre
d'états ou qui ont été envoyées par la
poste
et là c'est encore plus litigieux en fit
en pennsylvanie par exemple donald trump
a déjà dit qu'il ferait tout pour
empêcher le décompte de ce qu'ils
appellent les votes nuls c'est à dire
les votes qui ont été envoyées par la
poste mais dans une seule enveloppe au
lieu de deux et on voit sur les photos
que nous avions envoyé à ses commerces
qui se barricade en vue des jours qui
viennent philadelphie est là et la
pennsylvanie
richard c c'est ici que tout va se jouer
selon vous alors il y à deux états qui
sont plus qu état clé qui sont vraiment
des états absolument cruciaux c'est
d'une part la pennsylvanie qui dispose
de vingt délégués dans le collège
électoral qui ensuite élira le président
américain et c'est la floride qui en a
pourquoi ils sont cruciaux parce que
sans dans ces deux états donald trump
l'avait emporté de manière extrêmement
juste en 2016 et le coronavirus a joué à
plein notamment floride qui est connu
pour être un état avec de nombreux
retraités le chaos américain fait peur
et la donald trump semble avoir perdu
une partie de son électorat la
pennsylvanie l'équation est différente
vous avez deux grandes métropoles
pittsburgh à l'est et philadelphie à
l'ouest qui sont dominés par les
démocrates mais tout un arrière pays
rural conservateur alors la peur que
l'on voit avec ces palissades elle
s'explique aussi par le fait que
peut-être donald trump va avoir tendance
à déclarer victoire très tôt sur la base
de résultats provisoires qu'à ce moment
là ses supporters vont vouloir descendre
dans la rue et vous imaginez ce qui peut
se passer notamment dans une ville
philadelphie où les fractures raciales
sont absolument colossal en cas comment
richard qui est le favori de cette
élection
alors si vous regardez tous les sites
d'expertisé si vous consultez tous les
politologues américains le nom qui sort
c'est celui de joseph byden il semble
que les sondages lui donnent davantage
et que dans les états clés notamment
celui où je me trouve la pennsylvanie il
paraît capable de l'emporter notamment
grâce au renfort des déçus de donald
trump de tous ceux qui ne supportent
plus les comportements du président
américain mais il y a une énorme
question c'est celle de la mobilisation
aujourd'hui qui va aller voter et
notamment est ce que les jeunes noirs
c'est ce qu'ils sont supposés apporter
leur soutien ultime abbey dawn est ce
qu'ils vont se déplacer ou est ce qu on
compterait ils vont s'abstenir et que
les partisans de tram seront les plus
nombreux dans les urnes aujourd'hui
alors qu on vote encore et ça va durer
jusqu'à 20h heure locale c'est à dire 3
heures du matin pour la france
merci richard et et félicitations
puisque vous avez reçu le prix jean
dumur qui est le plus prestigieux prix
du journalisme de journalisme ans en
suisse et c'est évidemment amplement
méritée merci à vous
on passe donc à sa place à présent et on
s'intéresse ce soir à ce qu'on appelle
les territoires perdus de la république
c'est le titre qui avait été donnée un
ouvrage paru en 2002 et qui décrivait
l'émergence d'une forme de racisme
parfois d'antisémitisme et de sexisme
dans certaines écoles en banlieue et
c'est le thème aussi d'un documentaire
qu'elle cp diffusera demain soir à 20h30
dans des bas doc prof en territoires
perdus de la république il a été réalisé
en 2015
mais il prend évidemment une dimension
particulière aujourd'hui après
l'assassinât de samuel pâti à conflans
sainte honorine alors pour en débattre
j'accueille en plateau cécile rilhac
bonsoir vous êtes député la république
en marche du val d'oise et vous êtes
membre de la commission des affaires
culturelle et éducation nous allons
débattre de ce sujet également avec
gabriel holard saw vi qui est professeur
de mathématiques et co secrétaire
départemental du snes fsu dans le
val-de-marne et puis à distance en
visioconférence le réalisateur de ce
documentaire georges benayoun bonsoir on
va commencer avec vous dans un instant
si vous le voulez bien mais d'abord je
vous propose de regarder un premier
extrait de ce documentaire qui montre en
quelque sorte la pression sociale qui
peut être subi par certaines élèves au
lycée des élèves qui portent le voile
chez elle c'est une fille qui dans une
classe de filles et qui porte le voile
et quand j'ai fait une sortie au musée
du louvre elle m'a demandé de porter son
voile
donc j'ai refusé puisque elle est
considérée comme étant dans
l'établissement et elle m'a dit content
du coup elle ne pouvait pas venir et ça
m'a vraiment gêné parce que cette sortie
là je la faisais en grande partie pour
elle aussi pour des élèves comme ça qui
ne sont jamais sentis de mots qui n'ont
jamais rien vu d'autre
donc du coup je lui ai laissé porter son
voile jusqu'à la gare et à la gare de
paris aussi et après elle a dû enlever
dans musée alors elle a gardé parce que
d'après ce qu'elle me disait la vesle
aurait pu avoir des remontrances de ses
cousins assez violente
elle a vraiment faim elle m'a parlé
après l'avait vraiment extrêmement peur
de devoir l'enlever donc j'ai pas
je préférais jouer un peu la sécurité on
va dire et déroger un peu à cette règle
de la laïcité pour qu'elle puisse sortir
de mots aller à paris voir des belles
choses voilà donc pour le témoignage de
cette enseignante georges benayoun
d'abord est ce que pourrait rappeler un
peu dans quel contexte vous avez tourné
ce documentaire à quel moment
précisément j'ai tourné ce film j'ai
préparé j'ai commencé la préparation de
ce film avant janvier 2015 et j'ai
tourné le film après les attentats de
charlie montrouge et hyper cacher donc
j'ai vu la différence entre les les des
propos de deux des intervenants des
profs avec qui j'ai passé plusieurs
semaines en avant et après où il ya eu
une libération de la parole
véritable tout de suite après les
attentats qu'est ce que vous avez voulu
montrer à travers ce documentaire
franchement je suis rentré dans ce film
comme on entre sur dans tout le temps
dire dans un documentaire avec des avec
des idées un peu préconçues et en
espérant évidemment l'échangé et
affronter un réel
moi j'ai rencontré des gens absolument
exceptionnel des profs qui se levait
tous les matins des fois avec difficulté
mais qui voulait affronter les ces
difficultés là qui avait un amour
profond pour leurs élèves et qui se
donnent tous les jours étaient plus en
butte à des véritables problèmes qui
étaient soit sur l'assaut sur la
sexualité sur sur l'identité le
le problème principal face à l'usma j'ai
ressenti comme étant le plein principal
c'est le eux et nous c'est à dire j'ai
travaillé essentiellement se le rappelle
dans des collèges de la banlieue
parisienne où il y avait une une forte
présence de deux des enfants de
l'immigration en général ce qui avait
évidemment et il y avait toujours ce
problème de et nous c'est à dire le
problème vous dis pas faire de la
communauté nationale qui était le
problème principal procès après man
écoulé tous les os aussi d'un mot
georges benayoun
vous avez le sentiment que l'assassinât
de samuel pâtit peut changer la donne
sur la façon d'aborder ces défis qui
sont à adresser aux à l'éducation
nationale aujourd'hui d'écouter gemmeurs
pour le symbole c'est absolument
dramatique ce qui évidemment s'est passé
on né sait même plus de la colère
on a tellement annoncé beaucoup annoncé
je pense à vos collective des
territoires perdus de la république je
pense au rapport obin et à tous ceux qui
ont alerté sur ce qui se passait dans
l'école évidemment mon fils
donc il ya moins de colère que
d'amertume c'est à dire que quand on a
appris ce qui s'était passé avec eux
pour le pour samuel pâtit c'est juste
tel tristesse parce qu'on n'a pas été
entendu et parce qu'on le déni a été
cultivé toutes ces années donc je
j'espère je veux être optimiste et
penser que sa mort cet assassinat
terrible n'a pas été en vain mais je
suis très très sceptique
merci à vous georges benayoun c'est
serré à que je vous fait réagir aux
derniers propos de georges benayoun
vous êtes d'accord là dessus il ya eu un
déni sur ces problèmes
dans les écoles pendant plusieurs années
on ans
oui pendant une bonne décennie on va
dire que
il ya eu en fonction des territoires
peut-être le mot déni est réel mais en
tout cas une chose est sûre c'est que
les choses ont été minimisés pendant
deux pendant de très nombreuses années
et est minimisée on peut pas aujourd'hui
pour te faire porter la responsabilité
je pense à aa une dire à la hiérarchie
comme on l'appelle dans l'éducation
nationale ou aux enseignants c'est c'est
le pôle le problème c'est que les
enseignants
il ya une dizaine d'années n'était pas
du tout formés à avoir ce type de
comportement il ya une évolution depuis
la sphère des foulards de creil ce qu'on
va dire que ça va être un petit peu le
point de départ et après l'évolution
dans certains quartiers dans certains
territoires
justement un mot de l'extrait qu'on a vu
un ce témoignage de cette enseignante
qui explique la pression sociale subie
par cet élève qui a peur en fait des
remontrances de ses cousins et la façon
dont l'enseignante elle même a du coup
choisi un petit peu le bas de d'adapter
si on peut dire de déroger au principe
de laïcité pour la sécurité de son élève
on voit bien toute la complexité pour
les enseignants va de répondre à ces
défis et j'en suis parfaitement
conscience puisque cette difficulté les
moi même vécu lorsque j'étais
enseignante à argenteuil gelé moi même
vécu lorsque certaines de mes élèves
arrivés en effet volé au lycée se
dévoiler à l'entrée aller jusque
d'ailleurs dans les sanitaires pour
changer carrément de tenue et lorsqu'on
est fait je leur posais la question
puisque j'étais professeur de psn 1/10
et parce que c'est madame si jamais je
me promène comme ça dans mon quartier je
vais être traitée vulgairement et et
pire on pourrait descendre dans les
cales donc lorsqu'on est enseignant et
qu'on a en effet ce type de témoignage
mais il faut prendre des décisions vous
prendre des décisions entre eux cet
élève l'album we do dans le sein de
l'établissement
on respecte les principes de laïcité et
lorsqu'on sort de l'établissement
comment est ce qu'on continue à les
protéger et là on voit bien qu'il y
avait un problème parce que ça veut dire
qu'à l'extérieur du lycée
cet élève comme dans le témoignage eh
ben elle n'était pas protégée
et le pire c'est que c'était la pression
sociale elle venait la cité à
professeurs étaient des grands frères
c'est à dire que c'étaient les grands
frères en fait qui
ray la vie de cet élève là et c'est vrai
que ces témoignages je les ai vécus
monel gabriel holard saw vi est ce que
vous même en tant qu'enseignant vous
avez été confrontés à des situations
pareilles
et comment réagir dans ces cas là
franchement moi j'ai enfin j'ai peur
aussi que des fois on compte quand j'ai
lu la totalité par robin je trouve que
on a aussi tendance à vouloir chercher
des choses à tellement vouloir les
chercher qu'on fini par les trouver à
force de les gratter quoi pour vous
c'est pas un problème majeur posé c'est
un défi majeur posé aujourd'hui aux
indiens c'est pas notre quotidien notre
quotidien il n'est pas là nous ont fait
le choix dans certains établissements
scolaires
enfin par exemple de faire tout un
travail sur la question du consentement
des violences sexuelles et sexistes etc
mais c'est même pas spécialement demandé
par l'institution c'est nous qui prenons
qui faisons ce travail on nous donne pas
de moyens supplémentaires pour le faire
c'est souvent les collègues de sciences
de la vie et de la terre qu'ils assument
mais alors que c'est pas tout à fait
vraiment dans leur programme ça cadre
pas bien c'est souvent fait en dehors de
nos missions nous c'est un travail sur
le conte fait beaucoup et auquel on tire
mais je voulais juste faire réagir
georges benayoun je vois je le vois qui
secoue la tête en entendant vos propos
ce n'est juste pas possible d'entendre
encore ça aujourd'hui après la mort de
samuel pâtit sol mais plus possible et
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que voulait dire
enfin je moi je ne suis pas je suis pas
dans le déni de ce qui est arrivé à un
collègue la question n'est pas là c'est
parce que dans un discours de tennis et
c'est ce discours là qui est un discours
condamnant écouter matinal des
enseignants en banlieue ça fait ça fait
longtemps maintenant ça fait ça fait
plus de quatre ans que celui-là j'ai pas
l'épreuve pas moins que du jour d'époque
agrégé qui sont dans leur froc dans leur
lycée de saint denis depuis 20 ans me
disent que ils n'en peuvent plus
d'entendre votre discours ils n'en
peuvent plus alors vous même vous mais
vous avez quand même enseigné dans des
dans des établissements dans un
établissement priorité
l'enseignant à vitry-sur-seine c'est une
donnée essentielle on est en politique
de la ville
enfin je veux dire ces problèmes-là
enfin potentiellement on les a vus c'est
déjà arrivé qu'on ait des soucis avec la
religion
en quatre ans je crois que j'en ai eu
deux des cas comme ça c'est vraiment
mais en général c'était même pas des
problèmes les plus gros problèmes qu'on
a ne sont pas avec la religion
c'est effectivement il ya des problèmes
du pay avoir des problèmes de racisme de
faire des problèmes de sexisme tout ça
c'est des problèmes qu'on traite au
quotidien mais ils sont pas forcément
liés à la question religieuse sont pas
forcément liés au quartier dans lequel
on enseigne
franchement il avait aussi eu lieu
ailleurs dans d'autres établissements
je pense que il faut pas tout mélanger
non plus quoi cécile rilhac il faut pas
tout mélanger
je vous rejoins monsieur sait que dans
nos établissements scolaires
cela peut se produire en fait
aujourd'hui n'importe où c'est à dire
que c'est pas simplement dans les
quartiers dans l'est dans les banlieues
où on a des problèmes et ce ne sont pas
simplement là où je vous rejoins liées à
la religion c'est souvent des problèmes
qui sont liés en fait simplement à
l'intolérance et au rejet de l'autre
d'ailleurs que les situations qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans certains établissements
que moi aussi j'ai connu avant d'être
élu c'était l'autre il est différent de
moi et parce qu'il est différent je le
rejette et dans certains endroits ça va
être je le rejette parce que il est pas
de ma religion
à d'autres endroits ça va être parce que
ils pensent pas la même manière que moi
et ce qui est très important
ou pour les pauses enseignants c'est
qu'ils doivent absolument aussi trouvé
la force de prendre ce défi-là à bras le
corps moi je me rappelle j'étais
enseignante quand la charte de la
laïcité elle a été publiée
et on nous a demandé de l'expliquer et
je me rappelle la difficulté en 2014
d'expliquer cette charte de la laïcité
beaucoup d'enseignants ne savait pas
comment la présenter les seuls qui était
prêt à le faire c'était les professeurs
d'histoire-géo moi j'étais professeur de
ps mais j'étais professeur principal
aussi et j'avais mis en place un travail
avec mes élèves
essai - professeur de ps professeur
principal qui est mis en place ce
travail là parce que je me suis formé
parce que je n'étais pas fort mais je me
suis formée et j'ai pris à bras le corps
au début mais mes collègues 110 ça va
être coton maintenance a pas été coton
est là la grande découverte que j'ai eus
avec mes élèves c'est le débat c'est à
dire qu'enfin en face de moi j'avais des
jeunes gens de 15 ans qui débattait de
leur quotidien de leur différence et
bien en six semaines
il ya plein de tabous qui ont été levées
c'est une initiative personnelle que
vous avez c'est une initiative qui
enseigne aux barres
le gouvernement de l'époque puisque de
la charte de la lignée de la laïcité
c'était quelque chose qui a été mis en
place par la réforme fillon
et il a fallu qu'on prenne à bras le
corps les enseignants et tout le monde
ne l'a pas fait gabriel holard survie de
votre côté vous estimez être
suffisamment fort mais justement pour
expliquer de façon simple ce qu'est la
laïcité on ne pense pas du tout je pense
que pour le coup on n'a pas eu de
modules de formation sur la laïcité ou
le laury's était optionnelle est très
très faible sur l'année de formation je
pense que ça aux revenants ça vient
heureusement les enseignants c'est quand
même des gens que concours une culture
générale qu'on fait des études
donc en général en discutant entre nous
on arrive à trouver les mots justes avec
nos élèves à confronter un petit peu ce
à la fois nos ressenti ceux des élèves
en voyant avec les collègues des autres
disciplines ça il faudrait qu'on nous
donne le temps de le faire ne serait-ce
qu entre nous qu'on soit payé pour faire
ça parce que c'est pas le cas une grande
partie de la richesse et de la qualité
du travail du monde enseignant
en fait elle est libre échange informel
qu'on a entre nous dans les salles des
profs dans les cantines dans tout ce
travail informel qui est qui est produit
et malheureusement on n'a pas forcément
beaucoup plus aujourd'hui
ça c'est un vrai gros problème a précisé
mais derrière la laïcité oui qu'est ce
qu'on met derrière la laïcité parce que
pour certains la laïcité on voit le
ministre de l'intérieur aujourd'hui pour
lui et la laïcité c'est l'interdiction
de manger ce qu'on a envie je veux dire
c'était une position à titre personnel
qui représentent pas celle du
gouvernement il s'en expliquait
d'ailleurs là-dessus je veux dire et
c'est un vrai problème merci merci
beaucoup je dois interrompre l'émission
touche à sa fin je rappelle juste que ce
documentaire il est donc à voir sur lcp
demain soir 20h30 prof en territoires
perdus de la république quant à ce soir
c'est en chine que jean pierre gratien
vous emmène merci à tous les deux d'être
venu sur le plateau pour débattre de ce
thème
c'est la fin de cette émission vous
laisse entre de bonnes mains merci à
georges benayoun évidemment d'avoir été
à distance avec nous passer une bonne
soirée sur lcp à demain
[Musique]